[Music]
Afghanistan's military says the attack
against foreign fighters was successful
but once again it seems civilians
including women and children became
casualties sources in Helmand province
say the victims were attending a wedding
party on Sunday evening when they were
attacked as the rescuers attended to the
dead and injured a crowd gathered at a
local hospital waiting for any news a
plane arrived and bombarded the wedding
ceremony and some nearby houses
including my own around 50 to 60 people
were martyred and 5060 others are
wounded
this attack follows another last week in
eastern Nangarhar province when a strike
said to be targeting an ISIL hideout
killed dozens of villages working nearby
Afghan civilian deaths in coalition
operations have long been a contentious
issue particularly because of the
sophisticated weaponry used by NATO and
US forces even with them having with all
the precision weapons and all that you
know the up-to-date latest technologies
the civilian casualties were unavoidable
of course the underlying requirement for
all of this is good intelligence if you
don't have good intelligence often what
happens that you ending up you end up
targeting civilians the UN says that
more civilians have been killed this
year in operations by the Afghan
military and their coalition allies than
by armed groups including the Taliban a
report just published by the Ministry of
Health has further highlighted the
problem showing that in the past year
3,300 civilians have been killed and
another 16 and a half thousand wounded
from the bride' al jazeera Kabul